quelques heures avant leur fatidique ils
ont tout fait pour arriver à franchir la
frontière canado-américaine avant minuit
les informations par YouTube
internet quoi
je voulais toujours venir ici ou quoi et
même au petit matin certains tentent
tout de même leur chance le parcours a
été trop long pour abandonner maintenant
Honduras Nicaragua
merci je remette entre les mains de Dieu
sur la nature accepte comme renvoie aux
États-Unis je peux que accepter
désormais ceux et celles qui traversent
la frontière de manière irrégulière se
voit rediriger vers un centre de
Saint-Bernard de la colle ou leur
dossier est étudié des exceptions
existent pour ceux ayant déjà un membre
de la famille au Canada et pour les
mineurs non accompagnés les autres sont
renvoyés aux États-Unis
samedi après-midi venant tout juste
d'arriver à platsburg certains migrants
sur la route depuis des mois n'était
toujours pas au courant du changement de
règles
cette famille que l'on Bienne a voyagé
deux mois pour arriver ici
professionnel
a été difficile et coûteux elle ne sait
pas ce qu'il y a de viendra
ce qui sort de l'autobus sont épuisés et
mal équipés pour affronter le froid ils
ne savent plus où aller et c'est ce qui
inquiète les élus de la région
[Musique]
la déception est grande pour ses
familles qui ont dû tout abandonner et
qui voient leur plan bouleversé
marisabelle vous êtes toujours à
Champlain du côté américain de la
frontière alors qu'arrive-t-il à tous
ces migrants qui ne peuvent pas la
traverser la frontière
mais c'est la question que beaucoup de
gens se posent il y a des organismes ici
qui aident l'immigrants il se demande ce
qui arrivera à ceux qui ne pourront pas
traverser parce qu'il y a pas beaucoup
d'endroits où les accueillir dans la
région du moins à platsburg à Champlain
il y a pas vraiment de refuge non plus
il y a beaucoup de ces migrants que
parfois ils n'ont pas l'argent non plus
ils sont arrivés ici avec très peu de
moyens il y en a d'autres par contre qui
vont parfois les rejoindre la famille
qu'ils ont aux États-Unis c'est ce que
certaines personnes me disaient en
sortant de l'autobus cet après-midi mais
la situation varie en fonction des
personnes et on s'inquiète savoir
comment accueillir ces personnes qui
nous ne pourront rentrer au Canada merci
beaucoup marisabelle
merci